all right and we are live I'll or
podcast Lords a gaming dotnet with Lord
solving a building roar reactions
brother what did you think we just came
out of Star Wars could be correct name
now I fall in order from respawn no
doubt so what do you think Lord saw I'm
gonna give it to you first we just came
up what's your impressions I'm gonna be
honest with you man like when I first
saw it you don't when you get a respawn
game you take it at face value that's
gonna be a great game it's basically
uncharted and but the thing that
differentiates it from it is that the
combat mechanics the Jedi comment
mechanics that we've seen it before in
games like The Force Unleashed and
things like that this takes it to
another level on this true dodging this
in terms of the force powers that you're
able to use are pretty freakin amazing
and they only give you like a little bit
bit of what you can do right um one of
the moments that stood out from the demo
for me was when he used a power where he
slowed down time he grabbed a
stormtrooper pulled the stormtroopers
shot at him he grabbed the stormtrooper
and pulled the stormtrooper into his own
laser and killed him with his own stuff
the laser that he shot he shot yes he
used that combat is gonna be what makes
this game stand apart from the way the
game looks from the way the game
story-wise we already saw we are Forest
Whitaker in there Saul Guerrero so what
fans it's like almost like a prequel
right right what he was doing in the
past
exactly so to me it seems like all the
elements are in place for this game to
be amazing it's just a matter of
cleaning up a little a few different
things that we're playing on PC yes
there were some glitching we we had a
crash
we had one crash but that's that's good
it was raw it was a scripted um some
issues with some textures and some
wookiees and whatnot things of that
nature but beyond that I have to say I'm
really excited about this game I I think
honestly all they have to do is really
give you an abundance of combat options
and I think the game's gonna be
fantastic I'm really excited
Saul couldn't say any better man let me
tell you right now lord Cognito is a
Star Wars fraud
I don't follow it that hardcore I'm very
casual I know basics our universe I've
watched all the movies don't get me
wrong well as a guy that's like hardcore
Star Wars that's not me so for me the
game like this is gonna have to really
go over-the-top to impress me and solve
you let me tell you man
blown away again the combat mechanics
the melees that the dodging abilities
that the varied options in dodging and
then like that like Saul was saying like
there were times when stormtroopers were
shooting him and then he was able to
force freeze time use the enemies you
know bullets against him to kill them
the thing that really took brought it
from me personally is I'm a big fan of
respawn right and respawn is the king of
the wall run mechanics so when I saw
Titan for a wall running I was like
that's what I'm talking about
so I was good I was good to be on side
it's so easy I saw a skill point system
yes which to me showed a lot of depth
they look like these things you can
level up there's so much it seems they
can do and story wise that cinematic
single-player story that a lot of Star
Wars fans have been craving no
multiplayer no big games as a service
universe just old-school Star Wars Jedi
fights and one last thing the the the
the NPC's that was fight I mean nothing
ever sees the enemies he was fighting
there was one that almost had like what
is it Darth Maul kind of bay leg thing
so it seemed like you have your your
father enemies and then you had more
powerful enemies that could actually and
that's where it was good to see how the
combat really worked out you had guys
pairing you you had guys dropping you
spinning around so the combat seemed
like as it gets further in the game and
obviously with different difficulty
levels it seems like it's gonna be
challenging in a way that you would want
you know when you're playing as a Jedi
so that stuff really absolutely looked
amazing for me another thing that really
stood out is the fact that they're using
the Unreal Engine and sort of instead of
fraud or frostbite no frostbite this is
the Unreal Engine
honestly you could tell the lack of
uncanny valley nacinda in the faces and
the way they spoke obviously it wasn't a
hundred percent finished yet right but
you could really tell that you know the
emotions that were not you're gonna be
getting from these characters are really
gonna come through in a way there's
gonna make the story pop hopefully so
hopefully the overarching story is great
but I think all the elements are there
to be something really special that we
haven't seen from Star Wars in a long
time right for me I mean I'm in the same
boat so it's like again it's early we
haven't seen any of conferences you have
Marcus office tomorrow but that's just
tomorrow you know I'm saying and you'll
be saw but as of right now right now
Star Wars is that game for me you know
and I'm not again I'm not even a Star
Wars guy so I'm curious to see how it
goes again - nephews we saw one thing
with an AI stormtrooper are they was
fighting the Jedi guy was fighting some
spiders and it was like a I stormtrooper
god I wasn't really moving in a bat
again mine and it picks coupling of
frame pacing here and there again I
don't know it was I'm playing on PC I
don't know how far they are in
development with what they showed but
I'm confident that that stuff was so
minor that it looked like it could be
cleaned up so anyway that's what I got
iron lore podcast live roar reaction
Lords gaming at night lost oil we just
saw Jedi ball in order y'all yo wonder
watch our law podcast approve